[ __ ]
[Music]
so I just got off an email thread with
Caitlin and ela in LA from BuzzFeed they
suggested that I do a video with
Rachelle where I take her to a really
romantic spot in Paris sure the time of
her life I've just been traveling around
Europe for work for a few weeks and I
haven't really spent much time with
Rachelle you should have a few days or
it's just the two of us and do something
super romantic but then because I'm just
like one a cheeky bastard I can't help
but want to mess with this and do
something that's just genuinely gonna
surprise her and her dad he's over in
Scotland right now they haven't seen
each other for a while but she'll loves
all things whisky she's an absolute
expert her brain is like a catalogue of
every whisky imaginable and we should go
to the Isle of Arran
because we've always said we've wanted
to it's finally sunny in Scotland which
is rare so let's take advantage of the
weather right now it's affordable we're
living in London at the moment so it's
super cheap and super close plus we get
to hang out with her family I think that
this is something that she's gonna
really remember and hopefully value
Michele's putting makeup on right now
thank you not like going to Paris
although I'm lying right now it's lying
with a good cause I'm so nervous because
I never lie hey Rochelle you excited
about our trip yeah yeah how long has it
been since you've gone to Paris what are
you most excited about eating [ __ ] on
the road you look out people watch
finally we have some quality time
together yeah in the most romantic city
in the world
and say bye to the house my house this
is my breakdown on the floor
[Music]
[Music]
if we want going to Paris to be upset
sorry princess we're still going or
something okay
where are we going well you know how
three days off and we really wanted to
take advantage of it
to go to Paris yeah that's very generic
so instead I lied
it
and so maybe we can see your dad and go
to some whiskey distillery
actually they love
so we're not gonna Paris right now no
I'm excited
I just didn't know I think this is more
you but maybe I'm wrong no it is it is
not exciting see scholars I brought my
turtleneck because I was trying to be
French I'm sorry
since I'm a life how you feeling good
romantic holiday of your life
I mean surprises on me
[Music]
Aaron hopefully we can get tickets to
iearn tomorrow it's a beautiful day in
Scotland and they're not quite used to
this amount of Sun who we saw online
that most of the ferry tickets have
already been booked out so it's gonna be
a [ __ ] if we don't manage to get
tickets to go to art but I guess this is
the downside of not planning things and
go in a small country towns normally I'm
like super organized I over produce
everything in my life
Rochelle is always kind of the one
that's teaching me to take it as it
comes it doesn't work it doesn't work
her dad's gonna come so it's not just
gonna be the two of us but we knew that
going into it well I knew that going
into this I'm kind of just at a point in
my life where these things mean a lot to
me I've heard that there's a castle
there and some beautiful walks along the
path and everything is just a bus right
away so it should be easy getting around
I feel like I'm getting thicker though
if they doesn't get any worse
just woke up a little while ago because
she sounds healthy to come wait for now
a boat ride was actually sick a couple
days ago and I'm just been trying to
fight it I wasn't even gonna mention it
it's come back with a penguin dumb show
so a show you've never been on I've
never been it's been 40 years for you
Jim Wow
so you virtually know we got together
[Music]
[Music]
do you like it that
[Music]
actually I feel like this is smell of
all the Bali I don't know if you've been
in into theater before but imagine being
in like a perfumery that was what kind
of smell like no out in the fresh air
this is Rachelle stats the whisky to uh
Emma and now I just gonna explore the
island a little bit and see what we find
I feel honey it was so informative I
don't know that the shape of the still
affected the chemical reduction and
that's all it tastes good nice axillary
nice modern and you gonna share your
cake and all that walk through a castle
[Music]
was a bit odd hook he had what we did
seems absolutely beautiful
despite the nausea that just added some
drama it's nice to me to hang out with
your dad what do you think you for
criminal in terms of dates kind of just
like spontaneous okay fine I prefer the
outdoors
Africa walking around on an island
taking the boat out then hanging out in
the city it's nice so that's not a safe
Paris isn't a romantic place but I think
you can find it in different corners of
the earth and the whole time last summer
meet my friend wanted to surprise our
other friends for his birthday we came
up with this whole elaborate plan that
one of our friends lost her purity ring
at the beach so she and him went off to
the beach to look for it while we stayed
at the house and decorated and he came
back we all scream and it was so much
fun I surprise my boyfriend with an
ultimate date I took him to a PNC
Pirates game and afterwards we went to a
trivia wine night and I kept it a secret
the entire night he only knew where we
were going once we got there I surprised
one of my friends with a surprise
birthday party I invited all of her
friends and we sat in my backyard good
drinks we sent my pool she still tells
me that's one of her favorite birthday
memories so makes that much better
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel
subscribe here that was my
[Music]